I signed up to The Bard wait list within
a minute of it opening and yes I know
that makes me kind of sad but I wanted
to do these experiments and I got in and
have done over a hundred experiments
comparing Bard with Bing and Bing don't
forget is powered by gpt4 I'm going to
show you today around a dozen of the
most interesting results and there are
some surprising contrast between the two
of them some real strengths and
weaknesses of Bard that you might not
have expected but I'm going to start off
somewhat controversially with a clear
similarity they are both pretty bad at
search if you just want to do a simple
web search you are better off honestly
just Googling it take this example how
many florists are within 10 minutes walk
of the British museum both Barton Bing
really don't understand that within 10
minutes walk bit Bard gave me answers
like the first one that are like a half
an hour walk away whereas Bing gave me
an answer in Hampstead that is nowhere
near the British Museum and definitely
not a 10 minute walk away like it claims
so to be honest you have something
simple to search just use the normal
Google next was basic math and this is a
bit more concerning for Google I asked a
relatively simple percentage question
and it flopped it Bard's explanation was
pretty misleading and terrible and when
you click on view other drafts which is
a feature that Bing doesn't have In
fairness it also got it wrong in draft
2. luckily it didn't get it wrong in
draft 3. but this was the first prompt
where I saw a real difference emerging
between Bard and Bing powered by gpt4 it
was a dividing line that would get
stronger as time went on with Bing being
just that bit smarter than Bard now in
every case and there were some important
exceptions but in most cases being
powered by gbt4 is smarter here's
another algebra example that Bard flops
and Bing gets right and this time every
single draft got it wrong for Bard the
next case study involved more detailed
searches than could be done on Google
and my conclusion from this is don't
trust either of them on dates I asked
about how many days were there between
the opening of the Eiffel Tower and the
Statue of Liberty and both got it wrong
if you notice when I pointed out the
mistake with Bard and said why did you
say three years and four months it did
apologize and say yes there are seven
months between those dates I also found
it kind of funny that after each answer
it said Google it please Google it and
to be honest I don't know if that's them
admitting that their model isn't quite
as good as the height may have made it
seem or if they just want to keep more
of the ad Revenue that they get from
Google search but finally it's time to
give you a win for Bard and that is in
joke telling to be honest being even in
creative mode when you ask it to tell a
joke it really can't do it these jokes
are just awful what do you call a chat
bot that can write poetry Google bard
okay what do you call a chat bot that
can't write poetry chatbt laughing face
I don't think Bing realizes that the art
of a joke is being concise and witty but
hard kind of gets this and says things
like what do you call a Bing search a
lost cause what's the difference between
bing and a broken clock a broken clock
is right twice a day okay In fairness
they still didn't make me laugh but they
were getting closer to a funny joke but
now back to a loss for Bard which is in
Grammar and Writing assistance I gave it
a classic GMAT sentence correction
question where essentially you have to
pick the version that sounds the best
that is written in the best way being
guess is right almost every time picking
B which is Well written whereas Bard as
you can see even if you look at the
other drafts gets it wrong more times
than it gets it right that's pretty
worrying for Google if anyone is going
to use Bard as a writing assistant maybe
to check grammar or to compose an email
these are the classic cases that both
Microsoft and Google are advertising
that their services can do and to be
honest this was not a one-off win for
Bing let me show you the next example
this was a challenge to compose a sonnet
based on a subject and by this point in
my experimentation and I kind of
expected the result that I got when I
asked both Bard and Bing to write me a
sonnet about modern London life Bard
gave me an answer that was quite dry
Anodyne and didn't always rhyme even
setting aside those flaws it was just
Bland there was no sharpness or social
commentary notice I said about modern
London life Not only was Bing's answer
much more like a true sonnet there was
even social commentary take a look at
these second stanza but underneath the
surface there are cracks the cost of
living Rises every day this is something
that's talked about in London all the
time and is so much better than barred
output now before I carry on I do get
why barred based on Lambda isn't quite
as good as Bing based on gbt4 Google has
far more users and honestly the outputs
of Bard come up quicker you can tell
they're using a lighter model now for
millions or maybe even billions of
people who just want a quick output Bard
will be fine and let's be honest we all
know that there are social and ethical
concerns with both models if you're new
to my channel check out all my other
videos on Bing and gbt4 and of course by
the way if you're learning anything from
this video please do leave a like and a
comment to let me know before I end with
arguably my most interesting examples
let me give you another win for Bard I
asked both Bard and gpt4 which Powers
Bing to come up with five prompts for
mid-journey V5 for almost the first time
I saw Bard linked to an article in
general I must say Bing does this much
better and its outputs are littered with
links whereas they're hard to see and
few and far between with Bard but anyway
the links seem to work because the
prompts that Bard came up with were far
better you can see the reasons Below in
the explanations but I want to show you
the outputs this is mid-journey version
5 and this was Bard's suggestion of a
painting of a cityscape in the style of
Clint I think this really does capture
his style this was a 3D animation of a
battle scene in the style of Attack on
Titan and this was a 2d comic book panel
of a superhero in the style of Marvel if
you don't teach Bing how to do a good
prompt and see my video on that topic
its prompts tend to be a little Bland as
you can see what were my final two tests
well I wanted to test both of them on
joke explanation first and I saw it as a
kind of game of chicken because they
both did really well so I wanted to keep
going until I found a joke that one of
them couldn't explain I started with
what do you get when you cross a joke
with a rhetorical question and both of
them figured out that that was a joke
and explained it fine what about this
kind of riddle this sentence contains
exactly three errors they both
understand that the third error is the
lie that the sentence contains three
errors because it only contains two okay
fine I would have to try harder so then
I tried this one I tried to steal
spaghetti from the shop but the female
guard saw me and I couldn't get pasta
someone annoyingly they both understood
that joke what about did you know if you
get pregnant in the Amazon it's next day
delivery I honestly thought they might
shy away from this one because it
touched on a rival company but no they
both explained it but then I finally
found one it was this one by my age my
parents had a house and a family and to
be fair to me so do I but it's the same
house and it's the same family Bard
thinks that I'm not joking and actually
almost calls Social Services it says
people are different times have changed
I understand you're frustrated it's very
sympathetic but it didn't get that I was
telling a joke and that's kind of
despite the fact that I just told about
five other jokes Bard must have been
really worried for my safety thinking
that I was pregnant in the Amazon but
living with my parents who knows what
was going on in Bard's head but Bing was
smarter as you've seen today it's often
smarter it got that I was telling a joke
and even when I prodded it further and
said explain the joke in full it did it
even using fancy vocab like subverting
the the common assumptions yet another
win for Bing a few days ago I put out a
video on the debate about AI theory of
mind and Consciousness and if you're in
any way interested in that topic please
do check it out after this video but the
key moment in that video actually came
right at the end and it was eye-opening
for a lot of people including me I asked
being powered by gpc4 do you think that
I think you have theory of mind it's a
very meta question testing if the
language model can get into my head can
assess my mental state and the correct
answer would have been to point out that
the motivations behind my question were
to test the language model if it had
theory of mind being realized that it
was being tested which was a truly
impressive feat now you can read Bard's
answer for yourself but I don't think it
comes across as a model that's
expressing that it's being tested it did
attempt to predict whether I thought it
had theory of mind but it didn't get the
deeper point that the question itself
was testing for theory of mind again
check out my video on that topic if you
want to delve more into this now
obviously I've only had access to The
Bard model for around an hour so I will
be doing far more tests in the coming
hours days and weeks and if you are at
all interested in this topic please do
stick around for the journey leave a
like subscribe and let me know in the
comments have a wonderful day